I just said like are we gonna die like
what's what's happening to us like I
have babies please tell them please they
can't understand me but tell them my
babies at home like please like I have a
family like let me live it was an
extremely emotional episode of Keeping
Up with the Kardashians on Sunday as Kim
opened up about her harrowing October
Paris robbery and her sisters Kourtney
and Kendall and mom Kris revealed their
initial reactions to the horrifying
incident I literally stopped I almost
fell on the ground like I just stopped
tonight I mean they started crying in
the middle of the club you can't begin
to explain the emotions running through
your mind I just remember running out
the door and I grabbed my blanket
knowing that was Kim's favorite blanket
thinking I'm just gonna wrap her up in
this blanket as if that was gonna make
everything go away the show also
included footage shortly after the
robbery
when Kim reunited with her husband Kanye
West and their kids north and Saints in
New York City
[Music]
an emotional Chris looked on wiping
tears away as can warmly embraced her
little ones
[Music]